[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's nick wright the
co-host but in his mind he's basically
the host of first things first on fox
sports one
in the former houston sports radio host
patrick mahomes apologist and maybe
james harden apologist and uh wanted to
check in with nick wright who joins us
now good morning nick
what on earth does patrick mahomes ever
have to apologize for
making everyone feel bad because he's
too good
like what i don't understand oh i know
you've got kansas city beating who in
the super bowl
green bay okay it's very chalky it'll be
the a question for you okay
would rogers mahomes be the greatest
quarterback matchup in the super bowl
ever we've had montana elway
we had bradshaw stall back a couple
times we had brees manning
would this go to the top of that list
what say you dan patrick
is the match-up this weekend in new
orleans
better than that matchup even though
it's not in the super bowl historically
breeze and brady
well that's very interesting if they
were both at their apex yes
but breeze and brady yeah because you
would have the greatest ever
and then breeze who is somewhere from
five to nine
so yes i would say so but because brady
and listen brady the last five weeks has
made me look like a total [ __ ]
so he's been very very good but
obviously he's not
as great as he once was and i don't
think brees as close to as great as he
once was it seems like roger
somehow has reclaimed his peak and
mahomes just keeps ascending and
ascending so
i just think it's kind of where they're
at on the mountaintop so to speak
the most pressure on which player this
weekend
they're going into the those left in the
postseason the most pressure is on which
player
i do think there's a lot of pressure on
the homes because they are the huge
you're a double-digit favorite against
the browns and so i think a loss would
be
somewhat of an indictment on the way
they played at the end of the year i
think that they
put it in cruise control once they
essentially locked up the one seed
so aside from mahomes i think there is
massive pressure on rogers because
you i understand the rams have the
number one defense i get it
but at the end of the day it's in
lambeau and it's either goff or wolford
you're up against like and so so if they
lose that game
when he is going to be the league mvp
when they're a touchdown favorite
in lambeau it's going to be 25 degrees i
think that's a tough one for him i think
brady and brees are both kind of
free-rolling
and i think lamar and josh allen are
somewhat free-rolling because they both
got their first playoff win
last week they both played really well
last week and they're young enough that
i don't think anyone's going to kill the
loser of that game
yeah i'd probably go rogers because i
think we're looking at the bigger
picture of
what one more super bowl would mean and
mahomes has time
breeze and brady you know they're kind
of
if they win one great but they're
emeritus right now i i just think with
rogers all of a sudden you move up
the ladder i think in people's minds
when you add that second
peyton got his second but he didn't earn
that second
this is one of those where rogers then
all of a sudden you know farves only got
one
so i i would say let me ask you this
okay if rogers wins it
if someone says aaron rodgers
is now unquestionably this is so corny
sports radio but god i love it
unquestionably quarterback mount
rushmore
that he's minted there so brady is
locked in i would argue montana's locked
in
and i would argue peyton manning's
locked in i'm not counting red grange
and
guys who i don't know actually existed
outside of peter king's
memory like i i'm talking about like the
mod last 50 years
okay that fourth spot's open does rogers
slam that door shut if he gets it
what if brees gets his second well
that's the other thing
he could say no it's mine i have the
second most everything to brady
statistically
and now i have two rings so because the
thing for rogers and brees it's not just
they both only have one ring
they also only have one appearance so
peyton i understand the second ring
it was defense pushed but he got the
broncos to the super bowl the year he
threw 55 touchdowns
right like that was all him getting
there and he got a saint or a colts team
to a super bowl
where he was the driving force that when
they didn't win it
so i feel like the it's for what hurts
rogers and brees isn't just the one ring
it's also the one appearance you know
this dan
i'm a lebron james fan so i think
getting to the championship
is a massive accomplishment that must be
respected not denigrated even if you
don't win it
and i brought up lebron and i brought up
you know when we get uh
you know three great talents together i
think chris bosh
is as important with the miami heat
success
as lebron and wade are to this degree
he understood his role and every single
night he didn't cause any problems
i'll be a spot up three you want me to
play defense rebound i'll do all those
things
kevin love with what he did in cleveland
he understood his roles that
that third man in has a really difficult
situation
with the celtics did it yep great point
ray knew exactly what his role was there
and so like with the here's the problem
for the nets
let's just go through their big let's
assume kyrie comes back
okay kevin durant can't be the third guy
he's the second best player in the whole
league
he has to be the leading actor yep
kyrie's the third best guy but what his
skill set
is is not at all what the third best
what you're he he hasn't his whole
utility as a basketball player is
scoring is amazing ball handling getting
to the basket
he's not a great passer and he's a bad
defender so the only guy whose game is
suited to it
and the only guy who's ever done it is
hard
pardon the only finals he ever made he
can't he was the third best guy
he has led the league in assists he can
be a great
distributor now james harden has claimed
the only thing he cares about winning a
championship houston bent over backwards
to do everything for him
he torched it on his way out in pursuit
of a championship
if that's true if all he cares about is
a championship
then he is the guy that says i'm going
to go from
being the greatest scorer of my
generation and one of the greatest
scorers ever
to 22 points per game i don't know that
he's going to do that
but he's the only one who can do it like
kyrie can't do that
or else he's just not like i'm not
trying to disrespect him but
his skill set is so specific to having
the ball in his hands and scoring
harden's the only guy who can do it i
don't know if he will even if he does
that team is going to be horrifyingly
bad defensively
that team's i don't think going to be
good enough dan if kyrie
is being a good soldier and they didn't
lose
dinwiddie do the nets need to make this
deal
i don't think they needed to make it but
i do
think that there is a
fear of the lakers that looms over the
whole league
and i think it's like okay if we don't
have a big three
our big two's not better than their big
two like lebron's
better than everybody and anthony davis
is objectively
far better than kyrie so even if we have
depth the lakers added depth the lakers
have cohesion
so instead they're going in on a third
star and it is i do get it lebron's
the only teams that beat lebron post
mavs have had three or four hall of
famers on them so i understand
the philosophy but i just think that
if you're going to have to get through
joel embiid
giannis and then anthony davis and
lebron
having do you know who the back the back
up center for the
nets is it's jeff green do you know the
backup power forward for the nets is
it's jeff green's identical twin brother
also named jeff green
and the starter is deandre jordan to
have no front court
rim protection to me is a big problem
and i just don't think
i get why they did it i think it's a big
risk though
lebron's got there's a lot of upside for
lebron
if he would happen to beat a team that
had all three
on it you know just how we would look at
why
he beat you know that that talented team
well yeah i mean
yeah i mean lebron's first ring came
against a team with three you know
future league mvps and hardin
russ and katie his next ring came
against a team with four future hall of
famers and a
two-time finals mvp and people like oh
tim duncan wasn't good that year
tim duncan was first-team all-nba that
year and tony parker was second team
and his third ring came against a 73 win
team and his fourth ring came against
you know in the bubble and a pandemic
with no home games so yeah the fifth
ring
against this team i mean at this point
it's all like lebron much like brady
competing with ghosts the only they're
really competing with each other for the
title of greatest team sport athlete
ever because they both
clearly announced themselves the
greatest player in their respective
sports but yeah it'd be nice
but i wonder about this nick you bring
up brady and i see parallels with brady
and lebron because they got there
and they did lose when they got there
whereas if montana had
six super bowl rings just like
you know mike has six nba titles and no
losses
would we have a different argument if
montana had six super bowls no losses
as opposed to brady with six super bowls
and three losses
i think we would and i think that is an
indictment on the collective
intelligence of the country
i don't understand i've never ever
understood
this idea that you know what
michael jordan getting bounced early
and therefore keeping a pristine finals
resume
is better than lebron james at 22
scoring 48 against detroit carrying a
team there
and then losing like his last year in
cleveland
jeff green second mention for jeff green
today for him jeff green
was the second best player on that cav
scene once kevin love went out
they made the finals the idea that we
used that against him i've never
understood but a lot of people do
i we wouldn't do it if it were olympics
olympics we don't say well one guy has
four golds
and the other guy has four golds and two
silvers we're not like well
those silver medals really hurt you
they're like no that's pretty good
that's that's impressive we like silver
medals they're not as good as gold but
they're better than no medals and i'm
there with you i you know the the fact
that you get to play in a championship
game
as opposed to not getting in a
championship game it just means you lost
earlier
it's not like you didn't lose that's the
part that drives me nuts
you did lose people this stuff and i'm
not here to
you know bash michael jordan he's
definitely at least the third best
basketball player
but i i did they act like he played six
years
played six years and by the way they
they do this weird
memory hall thing where an iconic moment
is the double nickel in the garden but
that's a season i'm told didn't happen
because he lost there like the bulls
never lost they did i watched it
they lost to a team that then lost in
the finals but okay whatever what do i
know
you you went up a couple octaves there i
think mariah carey is pretty impressive
when she does it that was sort of a
mariah carey-ish
going up a couple octaves there yeah
you're you're kind of pressing my
buttons here do you notice though
something that's going on in the nba
dan it's an odd little thing there's a
migration eastward
the king goes west and all of a sudden
jimmy is like oh i want to make the
finals
miami's looking good the rockets play
the lakers in the
in the second round and russ is like get
me out of here
out of here i'll go east everyone's like
uh i'd like to make a finals before i
retire and the
kawhi is the one guy he's like i'm going
west too and it's like okay well
goodbye see you later so it's just very
interesting
i'm with you though but i'm with you on
the lebron bandwagon
i i am i i'm with you on it you're smart
it's the only reason i come on the show
and you
you're starting to look more a little
bit more like alan rickman from uh die
hard
alan rick oh chris is that the villain
yeah hans
gruber yeah i know okay i don't know
what to even to do
that's a compliment how's that a
compliment because he's a
great actor a handsome man well-dressed
actor
that doesn't mean he's no okay a great
actor that's awesome
you're gonna be if you if i were like
hey dan you know what you're looking
like
john gazzali you're not gonna be i'm not
i can't be like hey he won an oscar
it's did anyone ever call him a great
looking man probably not
so it's not nice alan rickman's a
handsome guy
and he wasn't a terrorist his his
character was
okay why are you all fire you're like
sensitive here what's going on
i'm not sensitive i just thought okay
who do you want me to say you look like
who have you been told you look like
this here we go
what a bad guy you are you know the
answer
because you guys your guys are gonna put
up the video there's all right
there's a soccer player named frank
riebery
who people say i look like but if you
put up the picture of him
he has a facial scar from like a car
accident i don't even have a facial scar
and people like you look like him
i get that i get early stage tom green
none of these things are
true i'll tell you real quick and i'm
sure we're like i was going to the
bodega by my house to buy a black and
mild
and some guys were hanging out outside
and i hear them talking
like as i walk in they're like dude
that's the guy that's the guy that's the
guy from tv and i'm like oh they watch
the show
that's cool i get my black and white i
come out and like what's up fellas
and they're like do the thing i'm like
the thing they wanted me to do a tom
green bit
i thought it was tom green
at least at least they sort of
recognized you no they didn't
they thought i was a funny looking
different guy
with a high-pitched voice okay all right
now we're we're really off
i'm so late i got to go here i'm up
against a break you know how this works
i don't want to be here anymore that's
nick right thank you buddy good to talk
to you
uh nick wright the co-host of first
things first on fox sports 1.